lo que alguna vez solo vieron en la
ficción hoy es una amenaza real a la que
deben acostumbrarse quedarse a oscuras
Y es que los alemanes están recurriendo
a cursos de capacitación para saber cómo
actuar en caso deberse en un apagón
si se va la electricidad Entonces ya
nada funcionará y Debemos entender Qué
significa realmente nada funciona eso va
desde Llamar a los servicios de
emergencia hasta ver las luces de la
calle apagadas y eso representa estar a
oscuras como la boca de un lobo en la
calle y luego en las casas también está
completamente oscuro y nada funciona los
cursos se ofrecen de manera gratuita por
la organización alemana de ayuda y
bienestar amparados por la agencia
gubernamental de protección civil y
asistencia en Casos de desastre la
crisis energética mundial impulsada por
la invasión rusa Ucrania y las sanciones
impuestas por la Unión Europea Moscú
complican el abastecimiento de
combustible al viejo continente
hace tres generaciones la gente sabía lo
que era estar sin electricidad hoy nos
damos cuenta de que apenas podemos
funcionar sin electricidad así que
puedes verlo rápido que se desarrollan y
cambian las cosas y sin electricidad las
cosas cambian prácticamente se paralizan
no moriremos por eso pero la vida diaria
se paraliza
con las reservas de combustibles casi
llenas Alemania espera evitar los
apagones y gracias a una inusual calidez
imperante lo que contribuye al ahorro